I'm Raymond Arroyo sitting in for Laura
Ingram update tonight on a story we
first reported here on the Ingraham
angle last month that shocking video of
hooligans throwing water at New York
City police officers in Brooklyn then
there was another attack showing an
officer making an arrest in Harlem
getting drenched with water then hit in
the head with a bucket in the days and
weeks to follow more shameful videos of
people disrespecting police have
surfaced these attacks are escalating
the New York Post reports chunk of
concrete bottles thrown at NYPD cops in
separate incidents horrific attacks like
these have moved from New York State GOP
lawmakers to propose legislation making
it a felony to dump water on cops but
some Democrats are trying to block it
from becoming law joining me now to
respond is Bernie Kerik he's the former
NYPD Commissioner Bernie first of all is
the inaction from the NYPD and from the
political establishment encouraging
these new attacks were seeing on cops
absolutely what it does it emboldened
these guys to go out and do this stuff
and they see it on video there's copycat
attacks so we're seeing it all over the
country not only in New York City in New
York City you know we've seen a number
of them but the New York City cops have
laid back haven't done anything they're
afraid of the mayor they're concerned
they're never gonna be indemnified or
supported by the mayor and I've heard
the mayor say well we're going to arrest
them well you're arresting them after
the fact only because of public pressure
the cops should not be afraid to do
their job because we have a weak mayor
and do it in the moment though in the
moment now there are plenty of charges
whether it's criminal mischief
disorderly conduct harassment assault
mom there's plenty of charges these
people could have been charged with but
they were not and basically when you
watch these videos I see cops that are
afraid to do their job because of a
mayor that is an anti cop mayor Sean
Hannity asked de Blasio about this just
the other night we're gonna play a clip
of that watch here's my question for you
every person on video that is a felony
committed a crime did watch justice
every single every
look at that guy will you promise
this is uncredible you yes that's not a
good enough statement for you that
everyone commits a crime will be brought
to justice that's America is everyone's
everyone in that video are professionals
who are police officers know who commits
a crime and they will bring this that
video
Ernie Carroll you know what message is
that yeah look at a guy that has
villainized the cops in this city dating
back to when his son was young and he
told his son that you need to watch out
for the men and women in the New York
City Police Department don't give me
this garbage now or everybody's gonna be
arrested that's that's not the mentality
of this mayor this mayor villainized as
the cops he victimizes the thugs he's
done it consistently and I think the men
and women in the NYPD know it I want to
show you this this is Governor Andrew
Cuomo he this is what he said about the
spate of complet acts the video of the
cops getting doused with water and
walking away was one of the most
disturbing embarrassing situations I can
tell you this if a state police if that
ever happened to the State Police I
would bet you my bottom dollar that you
would not see state police officers
assaulted and they turn around and they
get back in the car your response well
listen I'd agree with him that it's
disgusting and disturbing all that stuff
but it's the Democratic leadership in
this city and in this state in
democratic leadership around the country
that's emboldened the people Bolden
induces type of behavior if we had
governors and we had mayors and we have
legislators that were supporting the men
and women in law enforcement there would
be a different mindset the cops today
across the country dating from Ferguson
to now you know they're afraid to do
their job they're handcuffed
well we're hearing reports from Times
Square that on this fourth anniversary
of the Michael Brown affair that there
was another cop who was jumped during an
arrest trying to arrest somebody in
Times Square how long will this go on
and when does somebody either in the
political
a state or national level step in and
empower these officers to do their job
and protect themselves you know what
happens Raymond this goes back to Rudy
Giuliani pre-1994 things have to get
completely out of hand
the crime rate will go up people in the
city will be afraid and then and only
then will they elect somebody that gets
out in the street and lets the cops do
their job but until that happens this is
only gonna get worse okay do we have the
video guys we have the Michael Brown the
protests and this is just in by the way
and in moments you're gonna see the cops
attempting to arrest somebody and again
you have people boldly attacking these
officers while they're trying to protect
citizens in the middle of frankly which
should be a street and is now a
pedestrian Plaza watch this the cops are
surrounded by the by these protesters
I've never seen anything like this you
know what all I can say is under Rudy
Giuliani that kind of stuff wouldn't
happen who would not allow it you know
and for this to go on these cops are
basically there their coddling people
are afraid and the cameras make them
more afraid because they'll be
splattered on the honesty's I kids land
them I would I feel sorry for them and
the union leaders will tell you that
Bernie thank you so much thank you sir